we are seeing increasing numbers of
places both here in scotland and across
the rest of the uk
that are under local and regional
restrictions
and of course many of you will have
woken up this morning to hear news of
the potential for new national
restrictions
the bottom line here is that this virus
is on the rise again
our case numbers are not yet rising as
fast as they were back in march
but they are rising again and they are
rising quite rapidly
the percentage of tests coming back
positive is also not
anywhere near as high as it was back in
march but again
it is rising and as i reported yesterday
the r number we believe is now above one
across the uk uh this is particularly
the case in england right now
hospital admissions are rising icu
admissions are rising too
and while this is particularly the case
in england right now this should
sound a warning signal for us here in
scotland
too and while for the past few weeks
people might have taken
comfort from the low levels of older
more vulnerable people contracting the
virus i have to say to you
that that picture is also beginning to
change our most recent data shows that
the percentage of cases in the older
population
is now beginning to rise as well and
looking
more widely we can observe that in broad
terms we might now be on at an earlier
stage on a similar path to that that has
been taken in recent weeks by
france about four weeks ago france stood
broadly where we do
today but now they have around ten
new cases per day hundreds of people in
icu
and deaths in france are already
rising now as well so our task is to
make
sure if we can that we interrupt that
and we don't end up where they are now
and what lies behind this is a a simple
reality
we are facing the risk again of
exponential growth in covet
and we all know from our experience
earlier this year what that looks like
and why it is so important to seek to
avoid it
so i want to talk briefly about what we
need to do first and foremost we need to
act
to interrupt that exponential growth
no one wants to see another full-scale
lockdown
and above all we want to keep schools
and child care open because we know how
important that is to the education but
to the broader well-being
of children and young people so right
now and i mean right now today over the
weekend and
into next week that means following all
of the rules and advice
currently in place at work from home if
you can that remains
our advice as i said a moment ago avoid
if you can
non-essential travel don't meet up with
any more than six people from a maximum
of two households
indoors and outdoors if you live in
glasgow as i do or in east or western
bartonshire renfrewshire or east
renfrewshire
north or south lanarkshire don't visit
other households
at all at the moment unless you have to
to visit uh
to care for or deliver shopping to a
vulnerable person
the fact is we know and this is one of
the things that we have learned about
this virus is that when it gets into a
household
it is very likely to infect everyone in
that household
so to be blunt we must do everything we
can to keep it out
of our households and when we do have to
interact with others the
last piece of advice i want to remind
you of right now is to remember to
follow facts
all of the basic things that help us
reduce the risks
of transmitting the virus so these are
the current rules and
i'm asking everybody please to abide by
them
strictly and rigorously but it may well
be that if we are
to interrupt and break this growth we
will have to do more
over the next few weeks and this weekend
will be critical in the assessment of
how best to do that
as widely reported sage met yesterday
and i have chaired a meeting of senior
scottish government officials and
advisors
this morning to assess the current
situation
and discussions across the four nations
of the uk will i hope
take place in the coming days i've this
morning
asked the prime minister to convene a
cobra meeting over this weekend
so today i want to give the nation
advanced notice
that the coming days are likely to see
some hard but necessary decisions
if we want to avoid another full scale
lockdown which
all of us do doing nothing almost
certainly isn't an option
now i will of course as i have sought to
do throughout this pandemic keep you
regularly and fully updated
but for now over this weekend please
rigorously follow all of the current
rules and all
of the current advice